[Music]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  look let's go this way quickly  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  in five hundred years no one has ever  escaped in the going anywhere  it's the tower so stupid  this donut what's your name  trendline I owe you my life I'm going  east my way is filled with dangers come  with me  [Music]  my journey follows the Silk Road  the Great Wall of China something is  very wrong  [Music]  gather the people immediately make  everyone see that the dragon I must help  save  I've been waiting for this for a long  time  no don't touch this this is the helmet  of Genghis Khan helmet this is an  instant spark  when I have the seal of the Dragon I  will rule the world  [Music]  you know better this way  [Music]